لكل نجم ومشهور اولويات يراها في مرشحه او
الجهه التي يدعمها ويرى انه اكثر قدره على
تحقيقها مثل اهداف القضايا البيئيه وسياسه
حمل السلاح مثلا والاجهاض كان الممثل
والمغني جون ليجند الفائز بجائزه ايجوت
صريحا على حسابه على تويتر لدعم العديد من
المرشحين الديمقراطيين قبل انتخابات
التجديد النصفيه
صاحب شخصيه اند مان او الرجل الشهيره اعلن
مشاركته في حمله تبرعات لصالح مرشح
ديمقراطيه الاعلاميه الشهيره
دخلت غرفه دردشه على موقع الديمقراطيه
السيسي ابرامز لتشجع سكان ولايه جورجيا
على دعمها وعلى الجانب الاخر في عالم
المشاهير المغني كيدروك يعلن دعمه
للجمهوريين دائما وايضا المعلق السياسي
الشهير نيك ادمز كتب تغريده مرفقه بصوره
الرئيس الساب ترامب داعيا للتصويت
الجمهوريين لانقاذ امريكا حسب قوله ايضا
يدعم معسكر الجمهوريين نجوم اظهر دعمهم
سابقا لترامب مثل ستايسي دهش وكريستي الي
بالاضافه الى والد النجمه انجلينا جولي
الممثل جون بويت لكن دائما يقال بوليود في
صف الديمقراطيه